good morning believe nation today's
message is knowledge is the key over to
you watch me Matt is so much of
knowledge available today
what instantly and knowledge is the key
if you have the knowledge if you have
ambition if you are determined if you
are focused if you are committed use
this knowledge to grow everyone can do
it and this is what I would like to say
to all young men in India what do you
think I think to now that is very
important I remember last time I have
there's a group of employees staff that
meet apparently in the meeting room and
asking questions so ask my manager who's
doesn't really complement on staff so
we're not just with them and explain and
explain the agreements or the policy to
that employees and at the end of the day
at the end after the meeting my manager
came up to me said that you know you
feel well so I feel really good I feel
really good for someone that we that's
who never who hearty compliments on on
his staff
I think there's a lot of entrepreneurs
who hold themselves back because they
feel like they don't have the knowledge
and and I think because they feel like
the education there's so many people
feel like they could be a lot further
ahead if only they went to the right
school or only they had the right
education I mean I it's such a limited
belief because this isn't the same world
that it was 200 years ago right you can
figure out anything that you want to
learn by watching these videos right you
guys are filling your heads every day on
this channel learning getting better
it's not just about going to school and
getting the textbooks it's about
investing in yourself and just spending
the time to develop the knowledge the
people who hold themselves back because
of that limiting belief that I don't
have the right education and you got to
shake it because people don't care
what's what you went to it's all about
having the right knowledge and the right
information and applying it to your
business just believing in yourself so
thank you guys for sharing your morning
with us I'm curious about what are you
investing in yourself right now what are
you trying to learn right now what kind
of get better at right now I'm curious
leave in the comments below and we'll
turn the discussion thank you so much
for watching and have an amazing day
continue to believe and we'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another